for a week he's been silent a week in
which a decision that he made has played
out with alarming chaos
now back from his holiday back in the
white house president biden faced the
biggest test of his presidency
i stand squarely behind my decision
after 20 years
i've learned the hard way
that there was never a good time to
withdraw
u.s forces that's why we're still there
we were clear-eyed about the risk
we plan for every contingency but
i always promise the american people
that i will be straight with you
the truth is this did unfold more
quickly than we had anticipated
the core of his carefully scripted
argument was that staying there would
have been futile
there is no chance
that one year one more year five more
years or 20 more years
the u.s military boots on the ground
would have made any difference
but then what of the timing and the
manner of the u.s pull-out
the scenes were seen in afghanistan
they're gut-wrenching
particularly for our veterans
our diplomats humanitarian workers for
anyone who has spent time
on the ground working to support the
afghan people
a month ago in the same room words which
now sound so naive is the taliban
takeover of afghanistan now inevitable
no
it is not
there's going to be no circumstance
where you see people being lifted off
the roof
of a
embassy in the of the united states from
afghanistan it is not at all comfortable
now with an all-american backdrop he
danced a fine line for a home audience
claiming in one breath that this was the
right decision the only decision but
then arguing that he was forced to
follow through on a bad deal with the
taliban struck by donald trump
under his agreement
u.s forces would be out of afghanistan
by may 1
2021
in other words he argues that his
withdrawal was more controlled than mr
trump's would have been he does know
that a decision that was on him has
caused unease and upset among allies and
more than a wry smile from foes but this
speech wasn't for them
so what now the president had this
we will lead with our diplomacy our
international influence and our
humanitarian aid will continue to push
for regional diplomacy and engagement to
prevent violence and instability
we'll continue to speak out for the
basic rights of the afghan people of
women and girls
and so it was a doubling down of his
decision no regrets this was a message
for the people of america not for the
people of afghanistan